[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv78
pour un nouveau numéro du statut de
société comme chaque semaine nous allons
discuter d'un sujet qui fait l'actualité
près de 30000 jeunes seraient en
décrochage scolaire en Île-de-France
face à cette situation les différents
acteurs proposent des moyens des
campagnes d'appel des missions de lutte
des mises en place de partenariats alors
comment lutteon contre le décrochage
scolaire on en parle avec nos invités
faatan Idri bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
délégué spécial chargé du décrochage
scolaire à la région île-de-fance Pascal
Lefèbre bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
proviseur du lycée Charles baudler dans
l'académie de Versailles et Michel
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes vice-président
du conseil départemental des parents
d'élèves des ivines pour la FCPE je
voulais commencer avec vous monsieur le
fèv on entend souvent parler de
décrochage scolaire mais qu'est-ce qu'un
élève décrocheur alors je dirais qu'il y
a deux définitions au décrochage la
première la définition strict c'est un
élève qui sort du système éducatif sans
diplôme voilà ça c'est la définition et
c'est sur ce sur ce point que lutte
l'éducation nationale c'est pour éviter
que chaqueun élève sorte du système
éducatif sans sans diplôme par contre il
y a tout ce qui est en voie décrochage
c'est c'est cette définition beaucoup
plus large qui commence très tôtin dès
le dès le premier degré parfois ou le
collège c'est des élèves qui sont au
fond de la classe alors après c'est il
faudrait aborder les raisons he mais des
élèves qui commencent à à ne plus
écouter qui dorment qui peuvent
commencer à s'absenter et et petit à
petit cet absentéisme grandit et ça des
décrocheurs voilà le décrochage pour un
un chef d'établissement c'est l'élève
qui commence à à ne plus écouter avoir
des résultats insuffisants et et qui ch
comportement un changement de
comportement aussi et puis petit à petit
qui s'absentent et qui va sortir
justement du système éducatif et devient
cel qui n pas le diplôme à la sortie
voilà alors le 25 novembre dernier la
région île-de-fance organisait ses
assises de la réussite une journée de
travail rassemblant les divers acteurs
et partenaires de la question petites
explications
[Musique]
F est-ce qu'un bilan a déjà été dressé
de ces
assises alors déjà c'est ce qui est
intéressant au sein de ces assises c'est
qu'on avait plus de 400 personnes qui
étaient réunies pour travailler sur
cette question ce fléo qui est le
décrochage scolaire et nous avons
constitué 26 groupes de travail ce qui
représentait en totalité 104 heures de
travail cumulé avec les différents
ateliers et c'était aussi très important
et je l' je l'avais mis en exerg nous
avions 15 jeunes qui qui étaient sur
place pour nous apporter leur vision
leur solutions et donc c'est un travail
qui a été très collaboratif en lien bien
sûr avec des autres instances dont
notamment l'état et euh ça nous a permis
d'avoir déjà des des premières solutions
euh bien sûr nous avons nous nous
connaissons le bilan sur les chiffres
euh mais ça nous a permis d'avoir un un
un premier bilan sur les actions que
nous pourrions mener avec l'annonce euh
ça a été une volonté de la présidente
euh de de d'inclure cette cette question
dans la future agence de la promesse
républicaine mais aussi dans agence de
l'orientation euh c'est vrai qu'il y a
un un mot qui est revenu souvent c'était
le mot confiance ou en tout cas perte de
confiance chez les jeunes et donc nous
allons travailler dans ce sens-là en en
renforçant la campagne d'appel mais
également en lançant différentes idées
comme les écoles de production donc
plusieurs plusieurs solutions qui ont
été apportées lors des ateliers et nous
allons travailler pour faire en sorte
que ces solutions puissent trouver une
concrétisation dans dans des différents
dispositifs pourquoi est-ce que la
région a choisi notamment de de de faire
de la lutte contre le décrochage
scolaire on a presque envie de dire
souvent tout ce qui est contenu
pédagogique c'est l'éducation nationale
le lycée gère plutôt on va dire le
mobilier les les locaux là où le
département s'occupe des collèges et les
municipalités des écoles élémentaires et
maternelle
euh déjà je la la présidente de région a
fait du décrochage scolaire une
véritable priorité puisque déjà depuis
plusieurs années nous avons un délégué
spécial à la lutte contre le décrochage
scolaire et parce que finalement c'est
c'est c'est un sujet qui qui
traverse l'ensemble de l'île-de-fance et
comme ça pu être mis lors de vos
différentes pastilles même en ayant une
une volonté d'aller toucher les
différents décrocheurs puisque nous
avons nous appelons tous les décrocheurs
de l'Île-de-France une fois qu'on nous
donne la liste on a quand même encore un
tiers des jeunes qui ne sont pas
joignable donc il y a une vraie volonté
de la région en collaboration avec les
différents partenaires parce que nous ne
faisons pas tout seul nous faisons
notamment avec l'État il y a une
véritable volonté d'aller chercher ces
décrocheurs c'est d'autant plus vrai
qu'avec la crise
covid nous savons que la la la crise du
décrochage scolaire et c'est encore plus
aggravé alors on l'a sous-entendu tout à
l'heure m mais le décrochage scolaire
souvent en plus démarre peut démarrer
tôt c'est pas nécessairement une crise
d'adolescence comme on peut l'entendre
d'un enfant dès le CM2 la 5e ça peut ça
peut débuter alors effectivement nous
nous part icipons donc au niveau
départemental au au aux commissions
d'appel en fin d'année et il s'avère que
dans un certain nombre de de de ces
commissions et bien il y a des enfants
qui ont déjà des problèmes qui sont
très très important et sur lequel nous
nous souhaiterions qu' est une une aide
lors de l'année qui soit qui qui leur
permettent de pas en arriver à à faire
appel à une commission d'appel pour
passer à l'année suivante
euh en général il y a il y a comme on a
pu le dire il y a il y a trois facteurs
principaux qui qui entourent l'enfant il
y a la question de la santé la question
de l'éducation et la question du social
et il est important que que le les les
différentses personnes travaillent
ensemble autour de l'enfant pour arriver
à à à répondre de façon complète un
accompagnement qui soit le plus complet
possible oui parce qu'elle le fait on
l'entend bien la région une collectivité
les parents les responsables
d'établissements les professeurs il faut
que ce soit pris en compte comme on
parle beaucoup du harcèlement où tout le
monde doit être mobilisé le décrochage
en fait c'est pareil c'est pas qu'une
question pour les parents une question
pour l'éducation de chacun de son côté
non l'école quand même c'est'est ouverte
depuis un une bonne dizaine d'années et
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui seul on
peut pas on peut
pas lutter contre ce décrochage alors
évidemment l'enseignant à la base base
il lutte lui-même pour le décrochage en
adaptant une pédagogie en en parlant
avec l'élève parce que des fois il y a
des problèmes de motivation mais déjà il
il a des limites à ce moment-là puisque
il peut y avoir des raisons médicales
psychologiques auquel il peut pas peut
pas affronter ces aider l'élève dans ces
pour ces raisons là et dans les les
collèges et les lycées il y a aussi un
groupe on on va éviter d'utiliser les
sigles de l'éducation nationale parce
que ça va être compliqué mais il y a un
groupe de prévention du décrochage avec
l'assistante sociale la conseillère
d'orientation l'infirmier les CPE les
conseillers principaux d'éducation et
puis il y a aussi un professeur qui
s'appelle le référent décrochage qui
anime cette réunion avec le chef
d'établissement et on essaie de
justement de trouver des partenaires
trouver des d'autres solutions qui sont
pas au sein de la classe mais en dehors
et puis voilà on essaie de s'ouvrir et
puis lorsqu'on passe à vraiment le le
décroch rocheur en tant que tel là ça se
passe à un autre niveau et nous sommes
là que des partenaires sur des
plateformes alors on a parlé des listes
de décrocheurs qui sont qui sont pris en
charge et appelés par la Mission locale
il y a une plateforme de suivi auquel
participe l'éducation nationale on
essaie de trouver des solutions avec des
partenaires voilà aujourd'hui l'école
pour résumer votre ma réponse c'est que
l'école s'est ouverte et c'est pierre à
l'édifice de cette lutte on essaie
d'être au centre au départ et puis quand
la situation devient beaucoup plus
importante on est un partenaire parmi
d'autres parce qu'on n'est pas voilà
faut être humble face à ce décrochage
même si dans les chiffres on a parlé de
il y a 10 ans on parlait de 150000
décrocheurs aujourd'hui on est plutôt de
75 à 100000 pour la France entière euh
mais c'est toujours trop oui c'est pas
un phénomène nouveau moi on préparant
cette émission j'ai découvert qu'en 1980
39 % des jeunes sortaient de l'école
sans diplôme mais surtout aujourd'hui
les conséquences négatives seraient plus
fortes finalement le sans diplôme on ne
peut plus faire grand-chose aujourd'hui
c'est un sentiment qui est partagé
j'imagine par tous les trois monsieur
tan
oui je je pense que effectivement nous
on voit que il manque parfois des
passerelles c'est-à-dire
que on est plutôt pour considérer que
l'enfant est au centre et que la la
société euh et les adultes doivent
arriver à
s'organiser notamment se coordonner pour
arriver à les accompagner dans leur
développement et et à ce titre et bien
les les élèves et les les jeunes qui qui
se retrouvent dans ces situations et
bien ils sont
parfois pas accueilli aussi bien qu'on
le voudrait euh notamment j'ai
accompagné des élèves euh
personnellement pour les réintégrer
après une déscolarisation profonde dans
dans un établissement ça s'est bien
passé tant que j'étais là et ça s'est
moins bien passé une fois que j'étais
parti avec un une
une une approche qui n'amenait pas à
à à l'élève à vouloir rester en fait
parce
que parce que il y a un aspect de norme
et effectivement bah quand on n'est pas
tout à fait dans la norme d'ailleurs
chez les décrocheurs il y a tout type de
de profil hein euh on on en a parlé 2
secondes le le harcèlement le climat
scolaire en général peut peut peut créer
une chose mais il y a aussi des élèves
qui euh oui un cadre qui ne convient pas
certains c'est quand on dit n'être pas
fait pour l'école ce n'est pas toujours
péjoratif certains seront se sentent
mieux en peut-être en lycée
professionnel euh plutôt qu'à la faculté
euh c'est c'est dans ces idéesl queil
faudrait peut-être voir aussi pour
éviter de décrocher avoir une
orientation plus rapide les CIO on en
parlait tout à l'heure aussi alors je
veux pas monopoliser la juste par
rapport à la l'orientation on parle
souvent de de de de l'orientation subie
et effectivement dans un certain nombre
de cas c'est quelque chose qui crée des
difficultés par la suite euh avec
notamment plus de de de conseil de
discipline plus de de de rbellion quand
les les élèves se trouvent dans cette
situation ça je vous ai vu réagir
monsieur le F je vous donne la parole
ouii non mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous voilà on doit on doit
travailler main dans la main et on essae
on expérimente hein j'ai avec une
mission locale on a expérimenté une
convention qu'on espère voir étendre à
l'ensemble de l'académie euh pour
justement que la mission locale puisse
travailler avec l'élève qui est encore
scolarisé parce que une mission locale
normalement n' pas le droit de
travailler avec un élève qui est
scolarisé ce qui est dommage et donc
cette convention qu'a signé la la
directrice académique et le directeur de
la Mission locale nous permet d'envoyer
des élèves comme ça et avoir un appui
que l'on n' pas au sein de l'école voilà
des compétences qu'on n pas au sein
deécole ou ne pas se fermer sur l'école
madame Idri en plus la convention qui a
amené à ses assises euh vise à réaliser
l'obligation de formation pour tous les
jeunes de 16 à 18 ans qui est un
programme national
oui tout à fait c'est pour ça que nous
on travaille activement sur ces
questions-là euh et euh j'ai j'ai pu
vous parler justement de de la volonté
dans une des propositions de faire des
écoles de production euh la formation
c'est une question essentielle on a
parlé de l'orientation c'est essentiel
moi j'ai travaillé longtemps quand
j'étais vice-présidente en charge
l'enseignement supérieur sur un projet
de portail de l'orientation et c'est un
levier essentiel et la formation de
l'autre côté parce que bien évidemment
c'est aussi un point essentiel donc sur
à la région -defance justement c'est un
levier sur lequel on travaille
beaucoup on a on disait qu'on allait pas
parler nécessairement de cycle mais dans
l'éducation nationale il y a le réseau
focal vous êtes référent de ce réseau
sur
l'académie ça si je me trompe pas ça
intervient aussi dans le cadre de cette
obligation de formation et vous mettez
aussi le droit au maintien dans
l'établissement d'origine les élèves oui
alors ça c'est un problème très complexe
le maintien dans l'établissement
d'origine parce que je pense que vous
évoquez les élèves qui échouent au bac
par exemple et et qui ont un droit à
revenir dans l'établissement le problème
dans certains secteurs dont le mien
c'est le le fait que les classes sont
déjà pleines d'élèves de l'année
précédente et il est extrêmement
compliqué de c'est un problème de place
oui c'est un problème de place voilà
quand dans les filières technologiques
par exemple quand vous avez 35 élèves
dans une classe si les élèves de
terminale échou au bac les reprendre
dans l'établissement ça devient ça
devient très très compliqué alors on
essaie avec la justement dans le cadre
de focale de de trouver avec la mlds la
mission de lutte contre le décrochage
scolaire des dispositifs pour les
rescolariser mais je vous cache pas que
c'est compliqué parce que voilà ça
dépend des années aussi de réussite ou
de moins bonnes réussite
euh que ces dernières années ont été
particulièr
compliqué
michelan la FCPE aussi auprès des
parents fait des formations des
séminaires autour du décrochage scolaire
est-ce que vous êtes là aussi pour
informer j'imagine mais aussi peut-être
rassurer et mobiliser certains parents
pour dire aussi soyez une pierre à
l'édifice alors bien entendu on on on
pense et d'ailleurs je crois que ça a
été ça a été indiqué par le
ministre il est important que que les
parents soit en contact avec l'école et
et et que c'est ce qu'on appelle la
coéducation et que ce ce contact se
passe le mieux possible parce que c'est
un petit peu ce qui se passe entre deux
parents ça se passe aussi mieux en
général quand les deux parents se
coordonnent alors de de pour pour dans
l'éducation de l'enfant et donc ça c'est
une c'est c'est quelque chose de
favorable maintenant on souhaite que ce
ça se passe en réalité sur le terrain et
nous étions le 2 décembre devant le
rectorat pour la question des notamment
des nonremplacements et notamment aussi
pour la la la question de de de la place
du des parents à l'école et le non
emplacement notamment a aussi un un
impact sur ces élèves qui sont sert en
voie de de de de alors ce qu'on a
appelle
décrochage en France mais dans d'autres
pays on parle plutôt de persévérance
vous voyez et ça fait une
différence de sens qui est assez
importante entre le fait d'accrocher les
wagons et le fait de de de rendre un un
un l'élève actif enfin le jeune actif
dans son dans son parcours oui parce que
là vous vous élevez une notion comme
beaucoup c'est une question on dit quand
on veut on peut c'est pas toujours ça il
faut aussi j'imagine monsieur le fait
même madame Idri c'est l'accompagner cet
élève il faut que finalement cette
reprise C vienne de lui monsieur le fèou
madame idrce comme vous le
souhaitez je pas c la parole à Monsieur
le fè mais
oui juste pour rebondir sur les propos
qui ont été dits je je trouve ça très
intéressant c'est vrai les mots qui sont
employés parler de lutte contre le
décrochage de de parler de persévérance
c'est intéressant et et et parler même
de lutte pour le raccrochage euh parce
que je pense que finalement euh derrière
cette question là il y a aussi beaucoup
de l'émotionnel et je parlais tout à
l'heure de la notion de confiance de la
perte de confiance des élèves qui bien
souvent aggrave ou entraînent le le
décrochage scolaire et et et c'est sûr
que pour les élèves en fait derrière
toutes ces questions d'école de de
problématique de décrochage et bien
souvent il y a il y a des des des
émotions qui peuvent être très dures à
gérer mais également pour les les
familles c'est évident et puis bon bah
forcément aussi pour pour tout le corps
professoral et les chefs d'établissement
qui doivent gérer aussi cette perception
moi j'ai été assez marqué dans lorsque
j'ai entendu les 15 jeunes s'exprimer au
sein des Assises de la de la réussite
scolaire à à la région île-de-fance de
bah justement de l'ampleur de
l'importance pour eux de de la question
de la perte de confiance et je pense en
tout cas que sur les dispositifs qui
sont fait en collaboration avec tous les
acteurs il faudra qu'on a réussi à
travailler sur ce côté émotionnel sur la
perte de confiance et justement sur la
reprise de confiance pour ces jeunes
enfin tout le monde est capable moi
c'est ce que je leur ai dit on est tous
capable de faire des choses très
positives et des fois il faut juste
trouver ce qui nous plaît ce qui nous
intéresse certains ont la chance de
pouvoir le le faire immédiatement
d'autres mettent un peu plus de temps il
faut qu'on réussisse à accompagner les
élèves les parents dans dans dans ce
dans ce cheminement lorsqueil y a ce ce
afin qu'il puisse persévérer et se
raccrocher pour pas employer c'est vrai
ce terme de décrochage qui peut aussi
être un peu
on l'a dit il y a quelques minutes et on
est encore en plein d la covid est
toujours là on sait que depuis mars 2020
c'est un peu compliqué là aussi Monsieur
le F il faut il a fallu aller chercher
certains élèves qu'on nestimait pas être
décrocheurs avant cette crise est-ce que
ça a donné d'autres idées aussi pour
évoluer contre cette lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire oui on a dû aller
les chercher parce que évidemment ça a
accentué l'écart entre l'école et et et
certains élèves qui étaient déjà en voie
de décrochage euh maintenant il y a
aussi des des points positifs enfin je
parce que on est on est face à alors une
lutte pour le raccrochage et c'est très
ou la persévérance mais c'est une une
marée qu'on qu'on on est confronté à une
marrée sans arrêt de d'élèves que et on
se se fait on se contente de petites
victoires souvent et on se rassure avec
ces petites victoires quand on raccroche
un élève au jour au quotidien euh parce
que sinon il y a un peu espoir dans les
équipes face à cette marée de du
décrochage et en particulier le covid
l'a accentué puisqu'il a éloigné un
certain nombre d'élèves et on voit aussi
que les élèves qui qui reviennent à
l'école aujourd'hui de façon plus
régulière et à temps plein ont aussi
beaucoup plus de difficultés hein c'est
tout ça c'est oui c'est des c'est des
une année des mois qui vont être dures
oui parce que il faut récupérer un petit
peu le retard pris par par certains
élèves et y compris dans la voie
professionnelle ça reste pas simple
aujourd'hui pour trouver des stages pour
voilà et on est toujours dans cette
situation où on a peur que on reparte
dans un confinement et on se
retrouverait encore à nouveau face à
cette difficulté qui s'accentue mon t
c'est un sentiment partagé j'imagine du
côté des parents la covid n'a pas
rassuré sur cette situation alors il y a
un rapport du Défenseur des droits qui
est relativement récent sur la question
de la santé mental des jeunes et qui qui
montre qu'effectivement il y a il y a
une un un impact alors c'est un problème
qui était déjà bien bien présent avant
hein donc on que ce soit l'éducation
nationale ou la
région faut pas hésiter effectivement à
mettre des
moyens à ce niveau-là il y a il y a il y
a il y a une question de rythme aussi
effectivement certains élèves ont besoin
de de probablement de plus de temps
parce que quelque part les les raisons
du décrochage peuvent être très variés
et ça peut-être aussi
un un une réaction par rapport à à à la
façon dont les adultes ont
organisé ce monde euh et donc
effectivement il faut de la confiance et
il faut
recréer des éléments et prendre le temps
sachant que normalement il y a aussi un
maintenant on est dans la formation tout
au long de la vie
donc
segmenter faire des segmenter la partie
collège segmenter la partie lycée et
puis la partie supérieur ça n'a plus
trop de
sens c'est ce qu'on appelle la formation
initiale mais c'est important de de
créer ces passerelles et de faire en
sorte que les les gens puissent arriver
à à
à
avoir accéder à à quelque chose avoir
des perspectives tout tout bêtement
voilà il faut leur donner des
perspectives on a beaucoup parlé de ceux
qui sont en cours de décrochage je ne
sais pas si le mot est le bon mais dans
le sujet aussi on disait et vous
l'aveait dit Madame Idri un/ers des
décrocheurs sont
incontactables comment est-ce qu'on peut
l'expliquer alors ça paraît presque
anoda en 2021 d'une personne qui est
incontactable
en fait on nous donne des fichiers je
vais juste rebondir 10 secondes en
disant justement l'année l'année de la
covid nous avions 25 décroch 25000
décrocheurs l'année l'année avant covid
c'était 17000 donc on voit quand même
qu'il y a une augmentation significatif
sur l'île-de-fance et on nous donne ces
fichiers et dans ces fichiers on don on
nous donne les derniers numéros connus
et donc forcément les les numéros
certains changent de numéro très
rapidement très facilement euh donc qui
ce qui peut rendre finalement
l'accessibilité au décrocheurs plus
difficile c'est comme ça qu'on me l'a
expliqué parce que j'ai posé mon
également cette question là ça me
semblait assez important et c'est
surtout pour des questions en fait de de
premièrement je dis pas que c'est ce
n'est que ça mais de de changement de
coordonnées il y a on tombe sur des
numéros invalides ou des destinataires
qui ont
changé alors le tempsfil il nous reste
que quelques secondes j' dire minutes
mais secondes euh monsieur le FEM on a
bien compris il faut de la confiance
faut du travail entre partenair aussi
mettre l'enfant au milieu de tout ça
mais comment est-ce qu'on les accompagne
quel mot on utilise est-ce que il y a un
schéma tout fait ou ça dépend de
l'enfant enfin de l'élève parce que
l'enfant il peut avoir 17 ans ça dépend
du jeune on va prendre le terme de jeune
et puis il faut savoir que le décrochage
c'est pas un c'est pas un critère enfin
il répond ça peut être plein de critères
qui se mélangent
euh médicaux sociaux familiaux financier
parce que ça aussi c'est un aspect qu'on
a pas évoqué mais en lycée et et dans le
supérieur puceque j'ai aussi un BTS dans
mon lycée on s'aperçoit que des élèves
des jeunes arrêtent pour des problèmes
financiers parce que les parents ne
peuvent pas ne sont pas en mesure de les
de les accompagné ben je vous propose
qu'on s'arrête sur ces mots-l merci à
tous les droits d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation durant l'émission nos
téléspectateurs ont pu voir s'afficher
des placards il y a des numéros aussi il
y a des personnes à qui s'adresser on
l'a vite parler les CIO les CPE les
proviseurs les principals je ne sais
jamais si les principaux voilà j'ai
toujours un doute les chefs de les les
chefs d'établissements les les
directeurs les parents aussi les les
médecins aussi les assistantes sociales
ne faut surtout pas hésiter quand on se
retrouve en difficulté pour tv78 c'est
la fin de ce cette H8 sociétés merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau temps
d'échange et bien sûr d'ici là prenez
soin de
vous
[Musique]